The brain is,
has specialized subsystem,
but dynamic biological systems so you can muck about with it quite a bit and
it'll set itself up in slightly different ways.
So the systems aren't necessarily localized exactly the same place in every one.
But roughly speaking,
everyone has those systems and roughly speaking,
they're in the same place across people.
Now there's a lot of variability and it's one of the things that makes you know,
Mri studies in the life very difficult to interpret because if you average
across a lot of people,
what it means is you're blur things out,
you know,
cause you can only extract out what the commonalities and although you know,
they're getting better and better at dealing with that,
so.
Okay.
So
there's other ways that you can think about the brain too.
These are all approaches to understanding it.
You know,
there,
I would,
I would say it's a very,
very complex thing.
In fact,
it's the most complex thing near it.
You know,
there are more patterns of combinations of neural connections in your brain.
Then there are subatomic particles in the universe.
So you are,
I know you,
you won't believe that cause it doesn't seem possible.
But you can do the math and you'll figure out that it's actually write it.
So you're the most complicated thing there is and by a lot.
And so in some sense there's more space inside your head.
Then there is space outside your head.
It depends on how you conceptualize space,
you know,
because you can conceptualize space as the number of ways that something can be
configured and that state space and that's a,
that's a magnitude measurement,
you know,
and the distance between things,
well that's another way of conceptualizing space.
But if you're wanting,
if you want to think about big,
what's inside you is,
I think that it's bigger than what's outside.
You would certainly that way in terms of complexity,
unless you factor in the other brains know so.
So that's very much worth thinking about means that you know,
what we don't understand about the brain is going to fill many,
many books.
And one of the things we really don't understand his consciousness,
people just don't get that.
And it doesn't really look,
you know,
you might think that consciousness is an emergent late evolutionary function,
but it doesn't really look like that,
you know?
I mean,
when even when people become demented and,
and they,
you lose almost all of their higher cortical function.
There's no doubt there's still conscious.
And so consciousness might be way,
way,
way older than we think.
And in fact,
I think it's highly probable.
I don't think a hypothalamic cat is unconscious.
It's certainly a wake,
you know,
and distinguishing between awake and conscious is no easy thing.
You might say,
well,
animals aren't conscious.
It's like,
well,
you know,
here's the thing.
You know,
what people norm normally think is that humans are different than other animals.
And so before you anthropomorphize an animal,
you should be careful.
But I think that's complete rubbish.
I think it's exactly the opposite.
Before you assumed that humans have attributes that animals don't,
you have to prove it because there's continuity,
tremendous,
tremendous continuity.
And so it's right to anthropomorphize animals.
What's wrong is to presume a priority that humans are qualitatively different.
Now,
there are some very bizarre things about us.
Obviously,
you know these,
we have opposable thumbs.
That's a big deal.
We can grip things.
That's a massive deal,
you know,
and it turns out that there's another,
your,
your brain maps your body onto its surface onto its motor strip,
and it's sensory strip,
which are roughly here on the brain.
And if you take the motor strip or the sensory strip and you make a
representation of how it represents the body,
which is called a Homerun,
keyless wielder,
Penfield wilder Penfield still did this first at McGill university.
He,
I don't know if you know this and perhaps you'll be fortunate enough to
experience it,
but people who have brain surgery are conscious when it happens.
And that's so that the surgeons can figure out whether this little part is doing
anything important before they take it out.
You know,
it's a very horrific thought.